all right welcome back to Hannity ride
Hillary Clinton's blame game just
continues she has a brand new book as
you know and title what happened well
Trump happened now Clinton says it was
her former competitor Bernie Sanders who
quote paved the way for then candidate
Donald Trump to call her crooked Hillary
Schultz was not President Obama for his
advice regarding Sanders during the
campaign saying quote President Obama
urged me to grit my teeth and lay off
poor Bernie as much as I could I felt
like I was in a straitjacket it was
reaction Fox News contributor Tommy
Lehren radio TV talk show host dr. gene
allowed Fox News contributor Jessica
talk is there any she ever blamed
Hillary Uranus
does she have when did she ever blame
Hillary for being a horrible candidate
that is corrupt well she's not going to
sit there and say hey I'm a horrible
candidate but she certainly has talked
about some of her weaknesses as a
candidate okay but she blames Tommy
everybody but herself well of course she
did I think it's also important to
remember that she had to get help from
the DNC just to beat Bernie and now she
wants to blame Bernie the list of people
that she has yet to blame is probably a
shorter list and the one that she's
already using to blame everyone in their
mother for her loss Hillary what
happened you happened I like a little
bit more than what you happen and I do
thing we were just talking about this it
is important to discuss the dynamic
within the Democratic Party between the
progressive left and a more moderate
centrist bloc which is where Hillary
Clinton belongs the majority of the
party is Bernie Sanders went out there
and said that she was gorgeous Jolin
Ward with you might know this is true
over reached on Russia all right let me
ask gene allow I am going to rely on the
fact that you are a psychologist
don't ever psychoanalyze me you can do
Tommy and objects ago she does me all
the time okay but here's it there's
something wrong if you don't have any
introspective qualities I for example I
do a lot of wrong things in my life but
I know it and I I know every time I do
something wrong it's like ding ding ding
ding ding you know a little voice in my
head yelling at me but I could do it
anyway so you basically fighting it
Claire I'm nuts go ahead
in writing this tell-all Shawn I believe
Hillary exposed herself herself in ways
that no pundit no collusion evidence no
bleach bit could ever have done who
writes a tell-all Shawn bashing and
blaming her own party right after a
national election this isn't when you
write a tell-all you write a tell-all
years later this tells you that for
Hillary once and for all
case closed the American people know it
this was always about one thing and that
if you have to know about Hillary what
is the diagnosis we can't do that much I
won't ask you to do it don't do it when
people say Trump isn't it you kid okay
like this with other words already clear
1 1 it says it is Trump derangement
syndrome
oh and Gina has been up there by the way
and she's happy new President Obama in
his mental condition let's lay off the
mental and Tommy how does she not
recognize that she is crooked I said
it's like Hello mirror
take a look well here's the thing we
even if we're not talking about how
crooked she is which we know how I feel
about that subject the fact of the
matter is she didn't show up she forgot
the average American point that is on
her she can't blame anyone else for that
so they can you can have any theory you
want we can talk about Hillary's mental
capacity of her mental so you don't even
care about that show up show up in the
places where the traditional Democrats
would have voted for you you didn't show
up you lost
get over it go back to Whole Foods let's
move on all right guys good to see you
all thanks for being